well such a sight to see is meteor
crater which is just a few miles from
Winslow go there stand on the edge of
that you know 3 500 feet across 600 feet
deep and then imagine that what you're
looking at is an impact of a just a
cosmic spec the meteor crater in Arizona
was an iron object that was able to
fully penetrate the atmosphere and
strike the ground whereas the tunguska
object was lower density a lower density
object is going to explode in the
atmosphere once you get big enough
everything's going to hit the earth
directly meteor crater was produced by
an object roughly the same size
but an iron object struck the Earth such
an event happened today Phoenix would I
believe be destroyed